salve bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti è
finalmente ragazzi cito lital nightmares
2 dopo un sacco di tempo prima di
cominciare agazzi informazione
importantissima io ho già fatto la demo
di little light ma due no che sarebbe
l'inizio della storia di internet penso
che quindi questa in realtà è l'episodio
due perché non mi va di rigiocare la
prima parte che è tutta uguale alla demo
che ho già giocato un mesetto fa quindi
se vi siete persi il video della demo
andate a vederlo che non lasci in
descrizione o poi scrivete su youtube
parigi little nightmare 2 partiamo
esattamente dal punto dove ci eravamo
fermati e niente quindi cominciamo
seriamente la nostra avventura su little
nightmare eravamo rimasti ragazzi dove
all'interno di questo di questo buco
scatola le talpe dopo che siamo fuggiti
dal calciatore che ha tentato di
spararsi in faccia ma io la faccia non
cielo quindi non potrà neanche fanno
siamo io e ld that not a quanto pare a
intrufolarsi nei nelle nelle tane delle
talpe vediamo dove riesco a sbucare
speriamo di uscirne vivi da fa
situazione perché il discorso è proprio
che cesto gigante col fucile che ci
ammazza anche senza il fucile quel
discorso quindi magari non diamo le armi
ai giganti cit
posso anche prendere fermarvi in tutto
questo anche se non vedo il senso di sta
roba visto che mi sembra uguale tecnici
di te e devo americana sì sì perché ci
arrivavo io sto situazione però come
l'oblò col cose
certo per noi adesso come ci arrivo lì
visto che se lascio credo che la
situazione sia mi dai una mano zia che
caso mi tendi la mano a fare chi cacchio
sono spider man ma io ci provo lo stesso
madonna che è stato fatto ci arrivavo
anche senza la pa nostro punto è
bellissimo ovunque
sono sempre sul pezzo non si tratta di
saltare da qualche parte c'è una gabbia
posso entrare quaderno mi in gabbie ray
da solo che già ci pensano gli altri il
suo gioco
secondo me devo salire la solo per
scommetti devo entrare anno devo
slegarlo forse si lega al salto ma
questi si mischia dice eccolo c'è un
ingegnere mi scusi mi può aggiustare il
ponte che hanno le rubo il cappello e
quindi che poi ci i capelli raccolti
almeno a parte che voldemort tizio o
anche una faccia ciò una faccia
benissimo quindi non si capisce bene che
faccia ciò marcelo quelle importante
quella che mi date un cappello
impermeabile non è l'ingegnere stavo
capito male io frate mike agatax non so
se sei capire a sta cosa è questo quel
il calciatore della prima parte
però non si deve la zia la zia non
scendere 6 c'è ma perché problemi ci
stai ferma e non era il pci porca
[ __ ] non artigiane d'accordo è la zia
la zia ovvio che qualsiasi porca vacca
aiuto un televisore e poi dicono che
uomini e donne è un programma di
sviluppo non è vero ma da quando ha
salvato il culo via via via via corri
ricorda che non è tempo di romanticismo
di chi corre moltissimo
allora non ci fu tenuta sapessero manco
quando giocava ad auto sono morto
ovviamente non ho veramente capito come
ho fatto a morire però va bene ai a
corri salto gigantesco vadano anche
ansia stai qua stai qua della merda
nella merda tratto non capisce che siamo
qua salve ma c'è un occhio solo tra
l'altro c'è un buco da un solo buco e
fratello io andrei dei scene cambiano i
vestiti per mete ma c'è un cappello
veramente un bel no se si sa se
camminiamo lungo il ponte non dovrebbe
vederci perché siamo coperti dal ponte
stesso o il cappello tutto lercio la zia
è veramente romantico conte navigare
nella merda
cosa di software che devo anche mezzo
tuffarvi perché se no non ci passo che
schifo ho raccolto gli escrementi e voi
mamma mia ragazzi ma che schifo let's go
memories è però adesso ci pigliano non
ci piglia sun davvero mai che stupido
meno male che è stupido ragazzi le
scopre no fermati fermati perso no devo
capire un attimo come è perché quei
corpi quando svolazzano tra la pizza
abbiamo inter cure quindi occorrono
lietamente dietro la scatola occhio in
carica
bayer ha piena porta mafalda la porta
aiuto noi rimasta fuori anno che però
c'è chiudi la porta c'è un fucile c'è un
fucile qua
prendi il fucile brady lo spara gli
spara gli sparatutto dai che ce la
facciamo da chi ci facciamo spara fa che
è facebook my boys ma che figata
ma che figata l'abbiamo schiantato
proprio o zattera e si va via
galleggiando come in ratatouille devo
riuscire a no no questa è la porta
proprio quale titanic
solo che noi siamo degli uomi 15 stiamo
perfettamente ma ci stava anche leonardo
di caprio dal lotto twisted nada questo
all'interno dell'eu ronnie dopo uno
scenario post apocalittico è per questo
che ci sono le televisioni
o forse no o forse i ragazzi inception
ecco se la demo fosse finita qua sarebbe
stato ancora meglio perché secondo me è
molto più figo fare vedere questo perché
la tema era finita che ci buttavamo nel
buco invece questa cosa qua ci avrebbe
messo ancora più hype bellissimo ragazzi
è fighissimo
c'è un altro tizio salve mi scusi lei
che guarda la televisione ma è finito in
e donne non pensano vede ok me lo sono
sognato entriamo achievement sbloccato
temprato
chissà che carina comunque bellissimo
ragazzo veramente un atmosfera da paura
a è un vestito pensavo fosse un tizio
appeso va bene vieni mafalda ormai lei
si chiamava è la cittanova bellissimo ti
puoi muovere nelle vie della città me
fantastico carta igienica questa ci
serve grazie prendi prendi 3d ecco la
mappa o così c'è una scuola con un
orologio con dentro dentro un occhio
cioè quindi il tutor che adesso
sottoposti riferimenti agli occhi raga
chestrano sta roba
mafalda vieni qua che giochiamo la falda
che cazzo andata
brava la zia mi devi andare dall'altra
parte all'altra parte dall'altra passa
in spagna o buffon navale di tirare la
palla in porta la porta porco demoni
specchio importa la faccio io no con il
palo
quel palo mamma mia che palle giocare
con te non c'e la voglia di fare cose su
e giu non c'e la voglia di giocare a
calcio
voglio fare niente che ti dico andiamo
contro i mostri
se ti diverte di più questo stelle
scolastiche una scuola va beh sì si
capiva che era una scuola già la
giardina effettivamente solo un genio
comunque tutto veramente creepy e al di
là di che cosa è successo al mondo e
tutto veramente molto creepy e io l'ho
reso ancora più grip perfetto
spendiamo pure la luce che già non ci
non si vede una sega c'è una palla hanno
forse un orfanotrofio
non è una scuola non so non ho ben
capito cosa debba servirmi la palla
ragazzi ma
ho capito raga devo portare i cubi con
con l'occhio davanti il suo sicuro
perché le mancano gli occhi a quella lì
sicuramente lo portare quei due kubilay
la zia prendi l'altro fammi favore ma
prendi l'altro cubo l'altro l'altro
proprie quell'altro dove di questo
prendi prendi l'altro l'altro ea preti
porco del demonio
pensavo se io pensavo trigger asse
qualche vedovo tirargli la roba addosso
all'inizio a cosa serviva la luce fuori
a farmi capire che c'è qualcosa dietro
avevo già calci vedeva lo stesso ma va a
cagare sincronizzati dovremmo riuscire a
fare qualcosa in sincro che dici
il sincro eccola eccola perfetto
beh però sono veramente con il prison
break io cioè nel senso sono bravo a
fuggire le varie situazioni brava la
falla magari a tutt'altro nome ma per
noi sarà sempre va fatta ragazzi
importante questo let's go io non avrò
un nome ma lei c'era sicuro condotto la
reazione quando mi sa che casino la mia
mano la zia a milano vai l'udc non
fissare le grate zia non fissare le
grate lo so che hanno molta più
personalità di meco a livello di
amicizia ma io sono un buon amico te lo
posso dimostrare soprattutto che dalla
destra che uscirà un altro gigante da
quella porta
preferivo il calciatore di prima col
fucile posso dirlo non voglio sapere che
cosa che cosa c'è dentro la porta
facciamo finta di niente
c'è un papero nel secchio
non ho capito niente ma l'importante è
un caldo l'importante è capire come
arrivare alla destinazione fermati lo
zio c'è anche lo zio nel gioco c'è ma
faldo non lo vedete che sono io un
bambino come voi e non ha senso che vuoi
tentiate di uccidere i piccoli bastardi
tu porca vacca sbandato è andato là
dietro la smettiamo qua è un bait anche
quello che vorresti uccidermi e globali
mafalda ventura possono squilibrio
faccio libro lancia libro trigger alla
trappola trig la trappola la trigger a è
una trappola lo vedo non è che lo
stupido e non so come si fa però vado
dietro è tutto calcolato ragazzi la
volete smettere di tentare di uccidermi
sono come voi io non faccio niente teste
di bakhita chi siete
qual è il problema state combattendo
contro la persona spero che è successo
ma dietro scommetti a a lo sapevo che
parroco demonio mafalda mafalda occhio
non ci hanno la testa non hanno il
cervello non sa non c'è mannaggia
un po come me quando la squadra tre
vittorie bravo zio
io sapevo che cadeva sta roba porca
manca lo sapevo potevo fare niente lo
stesso mafalda dove sei
mafalda ma fa pezzi liszt
kroto e mo che faccio a caccia di una
bacca adesso no senza la falda non si
può continuare social per il martello
madonna come ve lo do in the echo la
testa di minchia a ti sta bene pezzo di
culo a lo ucciso per l'abruzzo te lo
meritavi che cazzo vuoi solamente al
sono incazzato come una bestia rara aia
portava su come avevamo avuto io ho
vinto io ero per terra ha beccato lui va
dai porca vacca non mi posso portare il
martello nome lo posso portarlo
maledizione vi farò fuori tutti secche
rodi bestia come se non ci fosse un
tuorlo land perché c'è qualcosa dentro
vedo che la fionda prendiamo poi ci sono
dei disegni c'è un po di roba ma posso
fare niente
sento qualcuno che fa bordello giorno
c'è una zia ragazzi c'è una zia però non
mi ha visto ancora credo che questa sia
un nemico comune comunque cioè nel senso
i giganti sono nemici comuni a tutti in
più ci sono anche si trova a quanto pare
no
ma veramente sta insegnando in questo
momento
ma sul serio mi fai vedere i compiti che
io oggi ho portato il libro sbagliato
per favore non li posso copiare manco
decentemente let's go my boys e si va al
bagno senza che la professione accorga
jolo c'è anche una botola limbadi in
alto a sinistra ci posso andare da
poletti mi sono salvato non so come
la donna minchiate brutta soffre di
cervicale voltaren la zia sono dentro la
scuola nicolò fabi
meno male che ho avuto la prontezza di
entrare nella scatola credo che gli
esseri umani sia successo qualcosa al
corno insieme non intanto a loro ma la
chiave l'ho presa lasciata quando
giocava a nolo messa proprio in tasca mi
sa non c'è una specie di inventario
perciò in tasca devo tornare
all'ascensore raga non so come porca
vacca no
[Musica]
vela figlio nel colletto già questa sta
controllando chi si è mosso
ero io zia però il problema che non sono
uno studente io sono un tizio che vi
sono venuto a caso puoi muoverti dal
banco e volendo non banca all'altro non
mi ha visto non mi ha visto mai visto
una donna che perrotta no che ti vede
porca vacca e stai calma però ecco la
perfetta
teoricamente se tutto lo ha eletto
non è andata bene ma mancato vai corri
corri la chiave
maria la chiave corri sant'olcese che
ansia madonna andare al cesso non è mai
stato così complicato a scuola va bene
divertente cioè se un po un po horror so
se ve ne siete accorti io me ne sono
accorto
non devo più rapire le persone bravo sì
questo è quindi posso prendere il caffè
non lo prendo vado avanti perché prendo
questo torno in testa poi no perché poi
ci sei tu che mi rompi le palle sia
prendo st fare mentre tutti gli altri è
bene quel che finisce con la testa rotta
dei miei amici 9 lett
no no
ciao
dovete andare a comunque ragazzi c'è uno
sturalavandini prego fatelo prendere
così prende non si può prendere peccato
comunque la figata sta roba
io lo vorrei mai essere punito da quella
lì è comunque stato sincero preferirei
qualsiasi altro tipo di punizione ma non
quella davanti
l'ha beccata in testa sono morto morto
qualcuno che si allunga volta di figlia
sicuro ma con la garanzia è sto gioco ma
che orrore santo gesù è cascata una sola
la bottiglia non ero io ce n'è un'altra
lì come faccio devo prenderla
appoggiarla per terra prende la prendi
la se non la prendi cade ma don budge
appoggia bene
si possa dire vai vai vai mai maicon non
so neanche io son dato ma fa niente
eravamo ragazzi rimasti agli esseri
umani che scomparivano nel nulla adesso
siamo al la fase dove si allunga il
collo a quei pochi rimasti 15 è successo
qualcosa nel mondo non si è capito bene
cosa
corri poi perché sono accorta vai vai
vai vai corri bravissimo perfetto non
dovrebbe arrivare qua sotto
ovunque ma non qua sotto vai vai vai bye
bye bye bye let's go ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi biblioteca che palle copre
parzialmente mi rompere le pace tra i
due milioni gli studenti che fastidio
non è che viene fin quando non ci arriva
let's golf non è vero mai dai sono vivo
non so come corli ce l'ho fatta
là dove voi è un problema perché adesso
di stato vi sono quindi inutile che
tentò di nascondermi corro madonna che
figata
posso andare intorno a sta roba
spezzetta nome di jandilla ragazzini
figli a 100 106 salto ma io ci credo non
sono saltato
[Musica]
grazie
non mi ha visto non so come catturò mi
vede se vado di fare questa girandosi mi
ha visto che mi stava dicendo mi ha
visto non mi ha visto madonna
vai via sei anche orba perché mi arrivi
mai fatto vedere e posso andare non si
può non mi ha visto
[Musica]
ragazzi sto gioco è terrificante
temporalmente la roma non ho mai visto
da dalla vita che gioco degli horror vi
giuro che non ho mai è raro che io vedo
cose del genere c'è veramente sono
esterrefatto non dormirò mai più ecco se
questo vi interessa però l'ho già detto
di un sacco di horror my questi in
particolare ragazzi da cappato credo che
io debba aprire la porta non ne sono
sicurissimo ma quasi
e strano che però non capisco perchè io
devo andare dove è andata la zia magari
c'è un'altra strada che non vedo proprio
la porta un porca vacca ragazze brutta
co tra tutte proprio dopo la porta ma
devo cercare un'altra strada proprio
quella tramandata lei vede ragazzi
concludo qui l'episodio di oggi perché
effettivamente ciò l'ansia a mille però
che il gioco incredibile ma veramente
pazzesco ce l'hanno fatto da paura io
veramente se io non ho mai giocato a una
roba così non sto scherzando è fatto
veramente bene non vedo l'ora di vedere
come va a finire però speriamo nel
prossimo episodio ricorda escono tutti i
martedì e tutte le idee tutti venerdì
quindi il prossimo episodio uscirà
questo venerdì non mancate come se i
ragazzi vedono piaciuto questo è un mi
piace iscritti al canale sul caso e
scriverò trovate qua sotto nel caso
l'avete visto era come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]